president Trump's Twitter followers are
puzzled over his newest message the
first one sent late last night was
unfinished it read despite the constant
negative press ko Fifi huh
the tweet was later deleted and then the
president tweeted this morning who can
figure out the true meaning of ko Fifi
enjoy major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning Jessica Sacco
Fifi yeah good morning uh meaning I'm
not sure what the meaning is I'm still
trying to figure out how to pronounce it
Gail you have one I'm going to go
because it's summertime with corn cob
it's very simple I can understand that
and I can say it on live television but
in all seriousness the president's
Twitter handle this time cannot be
blamed on his communications team
something he's been doing quite a bit
here at the White House he owns not only
the unknown meaning the mockery that's
going to come with this and the scrutiny
that's going to come with it but also
it's worth pointing out at a time when
Manchester England Baghdad Iraq Egypt
now Afghanistan have suffered through
horrific terrorist attacks and there are
ongoing questions swirling here at the
White House about the conduct of Jared
Kushner senior White House adviser
during the Trump transition it reminds
all of us that it's important here to
keep focused on the important as opposed
to just the interesting mr. Kushner is
volunteered to share with Congress what
he knows about these meetings White
House press secretary Sean Spicer
suggested Jared Kushner status as a
person of interest in the FBI
investigation into possible Russian
collusion with the Trump campaign
remains unknown your question assumes
there's a lot of facts that are not
substantiated by anything but anonymous
sources CBS News confirmed last week
that Kushner the president's son-in-law
is part of the FBI probe Spicer would
not discuss conversations between
Kushner and Russian officials about
establishing a back-channel system for
communications he also denied the
president was involved you're asking if
he approves of an action that is not a
confirmed action I'm not going to get
into what the president did or did not
discuss on Twitter the president
declared Russian officials must be
laughing at the US and how a lame excuse
for why the Democrats lost the election
has taken over the fake news ultimately
the best messenger is the President
himself he's always proven that
fresh off the president's first overseas
trip the White House downplayed German
Chancellor Angela Merkel's suggestion
I'll admit that under Godin that Europe
could no longer fully depend on the US
he has a lot of respect for her but on
Twitter again the president spoke
harshly of Germany citing a massive
trade deficit and saying Germany pays
far less than they should on NATO and
military Spicer denied a rift between
the longtime allies
I think the relationship the president
has had with Merkel he would describe is
fairly unbelievable the president's back
on Twitter and more nimble than he was
about midnight last night talking about
Carter page a one-time foreign policy
adviser to his campaign the president
said the investigation is still a
witch-hunt and Carter page should be
allowed to testify to clear his name
Charlie thanks major